he just lost the election the election
in China make progress in ending poverty
no way Bernie was done play to the
audience here a little bit but he says
that communists equators kill millions
is people who look like you agree your
third honeymoon is about the white night
for us exactly what the problem with
politics is about all right question did
China make progress in ending extreme
poverty over the last be just lost the
election China make progress in ending
poverty no no Bernie certainly not
compared to the United States Tommy well
it's not even close by throwing the
poorest Chinese citizens into labor
camps and killing them right yeah a
number of people objected under the
poverty line went down Bernie's gonna be
the next he's gonna have his own
signature line of Nike sneakers look at
how rich we are birdies do it a wealth
of Purell man thank you very much is
this what the Kardashians feel like I
don't know they just lost the election
Bernie just lost the election ISM if
people are listening he just lost the
election we're gonna look at the world
the way it is general rule don't praise
Hitler the Nazis ever no and don't say
that Communist China if you would say
that Communist China is yeah it's better
off today then 30 years ago as far as
the poorest among them sure that may or
may not be true but it does not exist in
a vacuum when compared to the United
States or other free enterprise
economies even South Korea you don't
have to go all the way across the globe
into another hemisphere China may or may
not have improved slightly and again
like you said Bernie we can't trust the
Chinese because you were condemning
Donald Trump for taking them at their
word that they were containing the
coronavirus but we don't have to because
you can compare it to every other non
communist country unless Bernie believes
that the poorest in China in Cuba are
better off than the poorest in the
United States and the truth is it's
seems like he does that's why he doesn't
understand that he shouldn't make this
argument this is the ISM and if you
don't have an ism people say I don't
believe in ideologies well guess what
Bernie does bide maybe not so much Trump
maybe not so much but Bernie does
someone like Ted Cruz does Bernie does
have an ideology and if you don't
understand ideology and if you don't
understand your ISM what your worldview
is doesn't mean that you have to follow
lockstep with the Republican Party but
you do have to understand how you view
the world otherwise you have no hope of
understanding why Bernie Sanders in 2020
when running for the President of the
United States is even thinking of
implying that China has done anything to
reduce poverty you have to understand
the isms his sucks you know what's in
here it's just water that's why they
call it acting what it actually smells
garlicky there's something wrong with
the water I think it's going through the
ice maker and we don't have we don't
have the baking soda in the fridge if
you liked this video subscribe hit
notifications or just check back every
single day because we upload a new video
every single day this is actually taken
from the full show a full hour show the
way upload every single Thursday click
that right now go watch the entire show
if you don't want to you don't you don't
have to but if you if you stop by you
know just don't bother me I'm gonna
enjoy my garlic water